stop overpaying for your phone mint
mobile lets you order from home and save
with plans starting at just 15 a month
making saving money by switching to Mint
the easiest New Year's resolution to
complete all plans come with unlimited
talk and text plus hide speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network love your current phone no
problem use your own phone with any mint
Mobile plan and switch easily in minutes
with esim get your new Wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com drunk that's mint
mobile.com slash drunk cut your wireless
bill to 15 a month at
mintmobile.com here here
[Music]
get out of the shirt it's like
aggressively wrinkled I know you look
like [__] what are you doing I love this
shirt but when it's wrinkled it is a
true how is it a wrinkled you're wearing
it in back to back apps am I uh give me
a coat or something there Peters this is
embarrassing
uh I wore that on the last one [__] in
my ass all right it's all right yeah
that's good this is good content the
people love the wrinkled shirt content
yeah good content really seems to good
you know I still have lovely oh we got
Stephanie and I want to try her paper
plan because we didn't try a paper plane
last time yeah Mark let's cheers
Stephanie thank you so much for joining
us hey
oh that's good that's a really good
paper plane wow where'd you learn that
where do you work
oh yeah okay
oh we missed all that should we redo it
I'm a pretty loud we'll do subtitles
is it tough uh when you want you got a
little turkey sandwich on your cheek and
they're like hey you [__] it is
devastating to bring McDonald's
[Music]
like bringing your kid to a strip club
yeah they're like bring them back in a
few years right right yeah that's tough
damn vegetarians about where is it it's
us
oh no oh yeah flat iron very close to
here underrated area
great spot that Nomad they call it now
yeah north of Madison but it sounds more
badass than it is Nomad yeah yeah that's
a hot spot you got the what what is it
what's that Park Gramercy Madison Square
Park Madison Square Park yeah that's a
great part Madison Square Garden was
that's why it's called Madison Square
then it moved to 34th Street there okay
hopefully it stays there apparently
baseball was invented in that Park real
fun fact Admiral double day huh that's
the guy who invented it who is it
Admiral double day whoa my favorite Star
Wars character
give that a goog though I might be
Admiral double day yeah the hell is that
that's a whole person huh wow crazy the
baseball had to be invented they had to
go all right we'll do bases
you'll you'll spit then you'll Pat my
ass like you know they had to come up
with all this [__] it says Madison
Square Park baseball
[Music]
I got a couple 18 45. wow it hasn't
changed the lick still slow yeah
definitely the players look different
yeah yeah they all look like fat tubs of
[__] back then now they all look like
Thor the long hair right oh I mean have
you seen pictures now that look like
Noah cindergard
yeah that's true but then you got the
Dominicans too oh man with the chains
this is what a [__] I am I'm like I
don't think I'd be able to swing a bat
with a chain that big around my neck
they're just like running while it's
bouncing on their chest yeah I know what
you mean I watch UFC and they're in the
corner after [__] fighting for three
rounds and the guy's like wiping [__]
off like hey just gotta cut that's how
big of a [__] I am like easy on his
face with the rag that probably feels
like oh yeah look at look at that fupa
he's got a fat upper [__] area like
that I saw him at Newark like a week ago
and he's just this big Oompa Loompa oh
that's a that's hilarious dude it's like
Laurel and Hardy [__] but he said you
slap his arm and ride the waves back
home from the airport Jesus Christ he
was in a big yellow shirt and everybody
was shaking his hand it was they looked
like big bird
that is terrible for him yeah I saw Bill
Clinton flying public when I went down
to Key West no way yeah wait Bill
Clinton Bill Clinton on a corporate or
commercial airline commercial airline
yeah damn he just had three well it
makes sense I mean how like flying
forever it's expensive I know but he's
Clinton he's an ex-pres yeah what do you
think he just he flew private for a
while and then he's on some [__]
sheets uh yeah good point good posting
flight logs I mean maybe Delta's not the
worst option yeah he was in some sheets
too but wow Clinton yeah how'd he look
let's eat McDonald's
sunken yeah wow he lost some of that
McDonald's weight for sure yeah remember
that he was he was a yeah he was a
chubby guy oh yeah heart surgery right I
believe so yeah remember that's Phil
Hartman's sketch of him at McDonald's
eating everybody's food that was a great
sketch so funny it must be tough to be
out of shape and a cheater
that's a lot of pressure on your on your
heart yeah yeah good point a lot of
anxiety Tony Soprano he was always you
know also Viagra is horrible for your
heart is it oh yeah good old Phil
Hartman ah look at Tim Meadows
Kevin Nealon yep
Arkansas
man who is funnier than Phil Hartman
nobody's better than Phil Hartman
Ellen Cleghorn
just a fat joke but it's so elaborate
but but it's like not playing that was
by the way that was the 90s like every
joke was like whatever Fatso and you're
like yeah we watched it you're like all
right you gotta lay off me I'm starving
you know that was also a 90s fat joke
but at least that was a little more like
cartoony than just I feel like a lot of
punch lines were just you're fat oh yeah
for sure with Chris Christie yeah if I
said fat up or [__] area I tried to
keep it a little classy
I was elevated fat humorous
sounds like a Brazilian restaurant
that's hard to get into you got you got
into fupa holy [__] I'm gonna try
Stephanie this is an old-fashioned you
made us let's share this oh
[Music]
if you don't mind
bags no no I got my own coming damn good
old-fashioned I got my paper plane here
I'll wait and then we I know you gotta
get out of here Steph we appreciate you
coming here and uh
any peeves Stephanie anything bothering
you lately
the Spy balloon ah
ah no I'm just kidding did you see like
the picture at least maybe it was a real
picture but it was like people throwing
things up oh really I don't know
I did not see that that's fun I assume
that's how Greta thunberg gets around it
seems like our mode of transportation
just waving like this yeah how dare you
um wow yeah what do you got there I know
you got your kids in the car downstairs
but uh other than that
oh really and is that a cool bar it is a
cool bar it's a small bar and there's at
most two of us behind it well we have
the um bar back there's a few more but
it's very it's very small and IT
services the whole thing so it's a
little hectic and crazy but once you get
the rhythm going it's really good all
right what's your favorite drink to make
there
look who it is
yeah
yeah yeah
all right
it's live it's live streaming like
Louie's special
yeah what she got out before Rock which
I think was intentional
oh yeah you know comic says Petty [__]
I think he was like oh Rock's doing one
I'll knock it out first but
we'll get into that later
oh okay can I hold off on the soup
bring the soup
yeah
four pieces of breadwork are you gonna
drink who's the Jew here this is so
confusing
I know
Irishman
tell me about hi everybody
Neil Brown and everybody
all right go on was this chicken noodle
I assume it's from a cart they wouldn't
give me an extra piece of pita
you got Street soup yeah wow I love it
so we'll see we'll see all right are you
vegan yeah I'm like at least vegetarian
sorry
um hi how are you this is Stephanie
hello Stephanie
um did I hear a Theo Von quote coming
we'll see oh okay would you mind making
one extra paper plane just so Neil can
at least try it yeah I generally don't
like hard alcohol you're gonna like this
trust me I will yeah
what are you guys doing not on my phone
on Instagram
I'm treating you guys be on my phone on
Instagram doing crowd work right now
what are you doing here I got a spy
balloon going up today actually I love
it can I yell out a suggestion to you
guys
the earthquake in Turkey great comedian
but you are grandfathered in and
mullaney just made it by a labia hair
with the uh not having to put Clips out
I think our level you guys you both sell
more tickets at me so oh okay I guess
it's working you guys we are aggressive
with Clips yeah you are we're both very
aggressive what is the plan what's the
plan one guy I've got guys going I never
heard you before somebody no I'm saying
how many do you try to do oh as many as
possible yeah if it's good I'll throw it
up you have like every day no no no I go
every three that's my move really thank
you yeah you're active in my thing all
right
[Laughter]
are you annoyed when you see that much
crowd work
no I I think I've asked you both this
individually I worry that just people
are yelling out the whole time if I
release crowd work [__] I just wouldn't
want people
yelling out [__] when I'm trying to do
other bits I do sections
shut the [__] up I'll get to you yeah
okay so a lot of times I'll do it I'll
say let's do this at the end or I'll say
all right let's talk a little bit like
sometimes I like to just break up the
material like if you listen to like old
Dangerfield he'd do so many joke joke
and then he'd be like he'd do crowd
working like I think he just is breaking
up that Rhythm yeah so many so Rodney
danger he's a comedian
um that I'm sponsoring called Rodney
Dangerfield you might want to drink some
soup it's pretty gross hopefully you can
slurp
what's going on fellas how are you good
tonight we just had Allison Breon so
it's nice to have a comedian because I
think she was great but it's different
energy oh she has like
um she wants to talk about like she
doesn't have bits she's got two
publicists here I made a black joke it
got weird but I did get weird but I
guess you know but she was she was a
great girl she was fun and she was
really good well that's the problem is
when you start dealing with better
guests you have to worry about like
that wasn't easy
um yeah that's yeah that happens I
didn't I haven't I've only had um
seven people on mine so far on my new
podcast blocks now streaming
um you guys these guys are both coming
up today and tomorrow uh but yeah like
I'm Natasha Leones doing it like just
once you're into like it's like okay and
you just kind of have to play that yeah
that would suck to be an actor I mean oh
why it's a job yeah well just I mean I
get acting is fun but you can't really
emote
they well it would I I would be [__]
petrified all the time if I was an actor
of course that's what I'm saying because
you can't you're just waiting for
someone like what should I say everyone
you meet you're like do you have
anything I can say right and we can
write a new joke they have to like
audition they have to get a gift well
she's making she's right and making her
own movies on a bigger level yeah where
she can make her own stuff I know what
you mean if you're an actor who's not
quite that big and you do the slightest
thing wrong they're like well we'll just
get the person who didn't say exactly
[__] about Asian people or whatever yeah
yeah that's terrifying yeah well there's
that the easily replaceable thing but
there's also like you can't generate
your own material right right Louie
Louie is back Matt Lauer's not there you
go you know that's a t-shirt
they should have sold that as merch
um
yeah you're absolutely right and you
can't yeah if you can you have to write
your way out of everything right right
and you need a publicist and it's it's
scary but
I think that's why comedy's so popular
because I think uh people like I gotta
go out and hear some [__] because I
can't say it right no one's allowed to
say anything so and then you
you guys have you got a little canceled
a long time ago a long time ago yeah and
then that was nothing but it was like
nothing have you gotten a you got dinged
once right yeah you get the Twitter [__]
every now and then you know but we're
all here right so that's the thing is if
you can like survive it yeah if you I
mean I still think the best way to do it
is just ignore it which is kind of what
I feel like you did yeah that's you but
then sometimes you can't like a Gillis
thing is this soup
[Laughter]
I'm gonna like this this is a good
cocktail is it sugary a little bit it's
a little tart a little very good though
she's a pro oh
laughs
that was not a fake noise it was not a
fake I didn't like that Drake noise I
was literally I can't believe people
drank alcohol really oh wow because I
don't like the feeling so it's not like
that's worth it right right see that's a
gift I wish I didn't like alcohol I
always say that save it for my podcast I
always say uh alcohol but drinking
alcohol is like uh it's like uh giving
oral sex
no one's there for the taste
oh that's good you know what I mean yeah
yeah
um but like a [__] you learn to love it
yeah over time but also you don't have
to woo a cocktail that's true too yes
the cocktail you're just like I'll have
a cocktail but you do have to like show
ID to meet you know what I mean like
like there is a level of like I'm doing
a lot of [__] to have to drink this bad
right it's not even bad just like not
the greatest flavor yeah but weirdly it
only to be 21 to drink you can [__] it
[Laughter]
is different than other people but you
know he's grandfathered into dating
literally yeah
uh yeah he's got the 19 now that's young
19. yeah that's the new one 19's too
young you can really model he can get
away with it he can get away with it but
it's too young yeah it's no it is to the
point where even his friends are gonna
be like dude what are you doing he can't
come out to the bar literally you can't
get in he has to like go out to the
parking lot every every couple minutes
like I gotta go uh feed the meter yeah
her high school was derailed by covid
legit yeah good point someone on Twitter
just said that about
that's wild yeah that's [__]
hilarious that's really that's a good 19
is too young what are you talking she
hadn't seen have his movies yeah
derailed by the portable phone like
literally he was in high school in
1989. yeah that's so insane yeah that's
funnier yeah by the spatial Challenger
um yeah so I don't know what we're
talking about uh we're talking about uh
legal age of
um sex yes yes you're married now tell
us about that it's wild it's all the
same but uh there's this the government
is involved as Stanhope would say yeah
but you know she wanted to do it I'm
trying to be nice
those rules yeah so what are we doing
here that was your vows like yeah all
right yeah that's yeah by the way by the
way the wedding is so it was beautiful
she killed it she planned the whole day
and it was really pretty you were there
yeah but it was uh it's so uncomfortable
there's so much attention the the house
and the the chapel what do you call it
literally performance shows every night
for much bigger audiences yeah it's
brutal yeah it's brutal you had it was
brutal because you had to be a person
yes exactly and being a person is so
much more exhausting than doing
stand-ups also [__] embarrassing it's
embarrassing I had eight that's when
people go people go I could never be a
comedian we should all go I could never
be a person
it's more tiring that's how it feels now
it's the point where my brother said it
a long time ago he said you'll you know
you've been doing stand-up long enough
when you're comfortable on stage and
uncomfortable at the grocery store oh
boy there's like yeah that's I don't
think any of us are there but that I
talked to Ronnie Chang about the the
amount of birthday parties we're able to
miss oh isn't it great I mean that
should be part of the offer when they
offer us gigs
you get 80 of the door and you get to
miss that brunch yes that brunch that
your girl really wants you to go to
because every big or every social thing
is you got to put a governor on I'm
putting a governor on my true self the
whole time you know and then when you do
a stand up you go all right Jews you
know or whatever it is you're dying to
yell out juice that's it you've got
you've got Jew Tourette's I got I got
Judas Tourette's you're right yeah but
it's everything it's Holocaust well
that's dude
black Trans whatever all the stuff
you're not supposed to I'm like Roger
Rabbit behind the wall and two bits you
know I just want to yell queef at this
uh funeral
um it is fun to be at the place where I
could say like hey fatties yeah it's fun
I get an Instagram ding they're like
we're trying to keep this a pleasant
place I'm like oh my God the community
guidelines now it's HR now we have to
deal with HR HRS that's a community
guidelines on Twitter uh not Twitter is
the last place oh because thank God
Saint Elan figured it out yeah well they
can't have porn stars are just posting
video those of them taking three dicks
they can't censor jokes that would be
pretty [__] up we're getting we're
getting dicks are better than jokes I
think now well tell that to lose well
well you have yeah but also you had that
do you have the joke about the the
locker room or the locker the thing in
the picture in your locker I don't know
like something someone's trans and
they're like oh it's a hero oh yeah yeah
I forgot about that joke geez well you
have so many great jokes and it must be
hard to remember
yeah
I don't remember it goes a little
something
no but it is amazing on Instagram that
they could just literally you've
basically seen tits but then you do a
joke where you just say the word Nazi
even if you're making fun tonight yeah
nope because it's a computer doing it
now yeah it's a d it's a robot that
can't detect sarcasm or irony yeah yeah
but Seinfeld once had a great line
somebody goes how do you remember all
the acts and he goes how does a cab
driver remember where to go it you wrote
it you know it you do it every day well
ways now though yeah that's true well I
was gonna say that's like an old who was
the Seinfeld you speak
uh no yeah they used to have to know but
he's by [__] up jokes sometimes do you
ever [__] up yeah oh yeah like when
you're when you think about changing a
word
but you don't you're like I should
rewrite that line
and then you're like on stage you're
like wait did I rewrite it uh as you're
going over the about to say it and
you're like
yeah I've definitely done that and then
you flub the line because you're
thinking yeah I get that and I was in
Vancouver with Gary veteran uh over the
weekend and it's you do that thing where
you're mid-set and you're like this
joke's not gonna work in Canada oh yeah
it's building to a reference and you're
like oh no I had a punchline that was uh
liberty liberty liberty and they were
just like oh I was like they don't have
that no oh [__] but then I got you get
to riff off that but I'm like you don't
realize it's one of the things I'm like
[__] I have to you forget it's right
there it worked in [__] Seattle but
just at two hours North yeah they don't
have venmo in Canada I saw Melanie have
a whole venmo bit and then he was like
you don't have venmo like like oh my God
you just realized do you know
that's happened to me most recently it
happened when I was doing a black room
and I had what I now realize I didn't
remember you said fathers yeah we don't
have those uh I had what I realized is
like a white closer and I was like oh
[__] like I'm halfway in what is it like
Dave Matthews what's the club it was
just it was actually about Louie which
they don't care about
you know what I mean like they just had
no
right yeah that was another great Louis
line he goes you find out who your
friends are yeah no they're afraid yeah
yeah but like on in L.A um you can't
still be listening to R Kelly and turn
on Louie right yeah exactly
uh so forgetfulness Canada now what else
is happening with you guys you're
married you're what are you doing I'm
single he's living it up yeah you're
single yeah I feel like I am a like you
guys had a baby and a slightly older
than you baby
where I have your vocal inflections and
like a bit of your [__] uh uh [__]
anxiety yeah and a bit of like I might
have [__] I might be on the Spectrum
you're right um and there's a lot of
joke autism in here yeah that this is
this might be uh uh uh early Mount
Rushmore
[Laughter]
on there
no joke autism yeah for sure but do you
do you uh uh light being single or is
that not your thing
it's got pros and cons I don't you know
what the past week I've realized I I I'd
like being alone with that includes men
and women like I like same A friend of
mine has an object it's it's Dorothy
Parker said it also but my friend said
it I think she didn't know
in terms of like being with a person she
said I don't always want to be a
perceived oh like I just don't want to
be like I just don't want two eyeballs
looking at me right like you got four
right here I hate it yeah no I'm saying
like I just don't want a person sure I'm
getting to the point where podcasts are
the only way I can deal with people
well no and it's like we get to talk
like the best of our thoughts right like
here's the thought I had that might be
worth discussing and it's a fixed amount
of time and and then we monetize it am I
right
um no but but I just don't always want a
person around and I
I'm just getting I'm just accepting it
more yeah because my show the block
shows now streaming on Netflix is like
uh it's a lot of it's like I don't like
that part of myself but a bit of it's
like
ah I don't mind it of course like I
there are advantages and I also think
it's easy to be a single guy than a
single woman because we don't have to
worry about like safety yes like
physical safety totally um yeah we're
two of the toughest guys out there Neil
I mean no but you're big you look like
oh you're tall so so like you would have
an ease like he and I will to quote
Brian Callan will keep you busy in a
fight we've got scrap you'll you'd be
we'd all open with sarcasm obviously yes
yes
predominantly black neighborhood and
went to public schools so without
zingers I would be still in a lot and
they called them zingers right
Mark let's hear some of those new
zingers
they call them snaps yeah back then I
love snaps that was good yeah sure come
on I had a book of Classics I had to
have the book on me in case I needed
them but yeah you're right it's uh we're
not tough I don't you have but I don't
but I also believe that whatever we are
all monsters and we could figure it out
if like we were attacked physically but
sure uh I think it's easy to be a single
guy than a single girl and I also think
it's um uh
uh we're in a fortunate position
like
um as a guy uh we're all fortunate
people like career-wise oh for sure
we're very lucky and uh and so like you
know it's not
it's not Decap I don't know some it is
DiCaprio I'm DiCaprio's age you guys are
younger than me so like it is getting a
little creepy right a little
somebody the other day was like you
can't date a 31 year old like that's too
young and to me I'm like
they're already ones very old
[Laughter]
I had a friend say to me that 31 is the
youngest I could go that's what I'm they
were saying like no they were saying
That's nose of god wow that was the
point was you can't go younger I wonder
if it's the same friend who said it to
us that's funny I'm trying to remember
who it even was yeah maybe but somebody
gets Beckinsale gets her a drover dating
uh well she's a hero yeah exactly that's
uh privilege on the ladies side I think
he the when I was talking to I think he
meant it in a way where it's like they
grew up with a different type of
internet and phones and they can't focus
in the same way but I think we're all
kind of married to our phones too I
think it's kind of got us all and it's
also kind of insulting like hey these 31
year old ladies they don't know any
better it's like well that's the hard
part is like giving a woman her agency
and then but also being like you're not
ready yeah exactly so you might as well
call him sweetie like look sweetie I
know what I'm like you can't handle it
exactly which one is it uh I got it's
both ah it's whichever one favors them
at the time you know the Ted Alexander
joke this is a great single joke is uh
being single with the struggle between
loneliness and Euphoria that's very
funny you know where it's like you know
loneliness right before you go to bed at
night Euphoria the whole [__] rest of
the time yeah that's a great job Billy
Joel line oh really yeah uh I have some
bad news that was actually guys that
wasn't Ted Alexandro that was Weird Al
Yankovic
he's wearing the outfit
yeah Patricia the great line of uh I men
don't want to be alone but we want to be
by ourselves or whatever yeah yeah it's
like such a profound Point yeah and I
don't even know if I want that sometimes
so it wouldn't matter why is it do you
think
it's that thing of judgment
I just don't want to be the ver I had
the thought this week I don't I may not
want to be the version of me that you
like the best
yes I just want to be the version that I
like the best who is on his phone if I
make changes it's because I want to make
them it's not because uh Fahim has a
great joke
uh Fahim Anwar the great guy yep
excellent I always said he was a great
opener he used to open for me and I was
like fame's great because he's got great
jokes and no confidence
oh comic uh so uh it's basically white
women just to expect that you're gonna
grow and change for them right whereas
like Puerto Rican women will be like he
just yells
that's great like that's just what they
so this idea that I'm supposed to change
to for her I believe personally in
relationships no notes oh I like that
yeah well I don't give up don't get
married no I know that's why I don't
think I would take I could take it you
want an fx show but what's out there is
Network yeah yeah that's absolutely
right I like just I'm I by the way I
don't give them yeah I don't give notes
so like
I it's all like as is yeah I'm like a
chef that's like no substitution
they always come like right when you get
comfortable that's what's annoying they
always come like two to three months and
you can't give notes out of the gate so
it's right so it's right when you're
kind of like in a place you're like oh
this is like kind of a cool person and
then yeah I hate you and you're like
[__] yeah what's that old quote um I
thought we were going straight to series
let's talk about women oh [__] expect
women get married to change expecting a
man to change and Men yeah men it should
autofill by now come on Google
I married you because I liked you you're
marrying me hoping I'll be different
later it's kind of a weird I've been
married man hoping they'll change men
more women hoping they will not yes so
each is inevitable and that's Einstein
for Christ's sake that's but we're doing
great comedy quotes Nick Griffin's
Einstein you know that one yeah about
how Einstein's divorce they should tell
you that oh
you take this woman to be your lawful
what a wife it should be do you think
you're smarter than Einstein that's
brilliant Nick Griffin some of the most
philosophical relationship bits out
there is Nick Griffin absolutely it's
insane that joke about the pull the
dating pool when you're young when
you're in your 20s it's it's like Adult
Swim and then in your 40s it's like a
like a public pool
I'm [__] it up but that's the basics
of it he's like so many in my face I
know I know but you know what it is it's
it's makeup like you know a woman's like
I gotta go out I don't want to go out I
gotta put makeup on that's how you feel
on your phone you're like oh I don't
want you to see me without the makeup
yeah you know charm is men's makeup
almost absolutely but I was thinking you
were gonna go the other way which is you
don't want to go you don't want to go to
a party because you don't want to put on
makeup yes you don't want to have to be
you don't want to not say Jew yeah yeah
exactly oh you gotta listen to small
talk and all that but it's you gotta oh
get out you don't say you got to be on a
little bit
yeah and then you say like that's stupid
that's your makeup cracking a little you
know but is it also that you're in your
head and you don't want to be disturbed
that's part of it yeah that's alone time
yeah yeah that's a buddy of mine used to
call it his name's Robert he would call
it Bobby time Bobby like I need some
Bobby time totally but also
it is embarrassing to your point like
how we spend our days oh it is
embarrassing when someone's like what'd
you do today or when someone goes you
must be so busy and then you flash back
to what you've been doing you're like oh
I'm very busy meanwhile it's been like
[__] looking at your toenails for an
hour yeah yeah scrolling YouTube yeah uh
but being just just being can feel busy
sometimes just being that's true just
that can drain you just think our job is
just be in your head and you train
yourself to be in your head and think of
jokes and then being with another person
and kind of breaking that Rhythm after
you make a living at this it's it can be
exhausting yeah uh Roy wood said that he
said it says when do you write he goes
I'm always writing I'm in the shower I'm
writing I'm at the store I'm writing
because you're just like uh what's up
with Cocoa Pebbles cereals in a bag now
or loofahs are weird you're always
thinking about comedy no it is that
thing where people are like you always
on you're like I'm always something yeah
yeah I don't I'm not trying to go for
bits unless I have I mean I find with
interacting with people like I try to do
as little as I have to yes and then
people like when they're engaged and
it's like okay now I'll do something yes
you can see otherwise energy slip
through it yeah yeah we had Nate on it
he was kind of a low energy and I was
like come on Nate and he's like I'm
doing found later I'm like oh I get it
okay oh he didn't want to like blow his
he was great and he's I love Nate I've
known him for years but I felt like he
was more low energy than normal and I
was like oh he's doing Fallon he's got
to like save it up before the fight yes
exactly perfect no no podcast before
Fallon you know the old saying uh he
also did not like Mark farting on him
that's true did you fart is that like a
thing you do is that a segment it is a
segment we'll be right back
um yeah what um when does that happen
like he went to the bathroom and I I've
known Dan I've known Nate for 20 years
and then still no excuse and he was like
do we have the clip of Nate's response
to it it was ugly because we've played
it a couple times
he's a comic I figure hey I'm not
farting on uh I'm with him I I would be
a friend of mine farted around me and I
was like ah [__] like I got like mad and
I said like I forgot how old you are
because he's in his 20s oh we've been
we've been on a tour bus lately there
there's a lot of farting that's fun it's
you can't you can't be that you gotta
just embrace it you know I would I would
have rules about what compartment you
can fart in that's actually not a bad
thing like if you gotta go by the
Barry's bunk go hang out by the bunks
monster like but not in the common areas
well I was telling him I was on a bus
with Bert Joey Diaz big J Shane Gillis
and me it was first of all it was a fart
off and it was like a sleep apnea
convention oh that's so funny it was
wild just five bucks
in a [__] bear cave yeah
um that's uh let's see this is
a tell wouldn't stay on the bus
oh really here we go look at that face
that is the face of death
hello
the headshake he actually meant it oh he
was pissed [__] that's [__] looks sad
yeah yeah Saturday night like my dad's
not coming I gotta say Nate's gotten
cuter when he he's really cute and he
lost weight and the gray works for him
no drinking yeah that's what and uh and
he's really like having a really great
second act yes yes to life well and the
money too it doesn't hurt the money
probably isn't killing him yeah that was
like Eminem if he had like a CBS sitcom
I could see it like a country Eminem the
uh he's getting to the point where he
probably has more money than he knows
what to do with them oh yeah the Arenas
like is he doing Arenas he's doing the
Bridgestone coming up he's doing Arena's
in like weird cities too like places
that don't happen in cities I couldn't
sell out a club exactly yeah they're
like that guy he knows black people yeah
that's exactly
um we should stay away uh look at that
that's what I knew Nate they could see
me in the corner laughing at his uh
that's funny joke about it hey that guy
I love farting yeah exactly that's fat
[__] that guy that fat [__] love farting
and wings yep and like I don't know what
My Name is Earl but the best part is
that Nate is in the middle of like what
he thinks is an important thought yeah
there and Mark just goes hold on like
the
disrespect
everybody's a star of their own their
own uh operation exactly they were
having a fart you were doing a fart
sitcom we talked about your special on
on this podcast before because we both
really liked it thank you very much
really really funny you both text you
know what's interesting is and you guys
will maybe not this special but the
special after that
although you people stop watching your
specials yeah of course people mean not
like viewers people stop complimenting
you uh
oh I so it's nice when you get Comics I
mean comic stuff they just go like oh
yeah oh yeah you got one it just becomes
like a thing whereas because it feels
like homework
to watch specials yes and no it feels
like I know you mean like opposition
research but at the same time but I mean
but I also mean like I like comedy yeah
so it is there is part of it it is
homework but like
I only watch Comedy and documentaries so
I don't mind I'm happy when like oh a
good exactly a good comedian is gonna do
comedy like great give me yeah because
there's so many specials and so many bad
ones but I don't want too many jokes in
my butt I don't want too many jokes in
my head thankfully it was only 40
minutes
43. but uh but uh you know I by the way
you know I'm sick of putting out long
specials I'm kind of just like why why
I'm with you much I I don't think it has
he Comics putting out like an hour 20
and I'm like all the data saying that
people are gone by the 20th minute
exactly exactly Billboard's an hour and
a half I'm like Bill save that last
story
he can rant it out yeah I mean his last
one was killer too but I mean uh but I
also am very late to specials like it'll
take me like a year to watch a new
special yeah at the time but Mark was
like you got to watch Neil's new one you
got to watch Neil's newest okay so I was
like I made it a point to watch it and I
was like man it's just really uh
great observational jokes man like I
love the when I hear a premise that's
been done today and there's a new spin
that's why I love the dog rescue yeah
yeah you found it you found an angle
that's like those are my favorite like
well I don't want to call any premise
hack but when it feels like a premise
I'm like oh here we go well it's like no
one was allowed to do airplane jokes for
15 years until Louie did it exactly like
you're uh like a Greek god flying
through the air like give it a sec that
thing yes literally you were a hack if
you did Airline jokes before that sounds
true and then he did it and Sebastian
had a decent Airline this is a great
Airline oh yeah Joe list I mean there's
people who have great Airline bits but
it's like you know yeah I hear you
premises but then it's also like you get
you can make the argument like marriage
jokes are hacked but it's like all right
well then watch like Tom Papa or yeah
yeah people have great marriage jokes
you know yeah people go like why do you
make fun of men and women and I'm like
because Patrice called me and told me I
was good at it
literally Rock and Patrice told me I was
good at it do you mind right right do
you mind some guy if I keep doing they
people think it's
people from the outside can notice like
Airline jokes are hacky or gender jokes
or hacker relationship or whatever and
it's like and race jokes are tacky oh
you still doing that white people black
people [__] yeah I'm pretty good at it
yeah they both well you have one of my
favorite ones of those too the joke
about uh you know white people what
we've done felonies why why are you
calling us a misdemeanors which how does
that one go again you know what white
people you stole uh you stole Jazz yeah
that's actually not my joke I don't
think no it is it's your bit I remember
I remember this before Oh that's that is
a good no that's I because I'm thinking
of that's great I feel like a young Mark
Norman where people are telling me bits
I've done you had the one about ride in
the back of the squad car yeah that's a
good one that's a great you know the one
time but we say you still Jazz you're
like yeah we've done felonies why are
you calling us on misdemeanor that's a
great job
that's great good for me yeah um that
was I was like a good race race jokes
are tough yeah they are harder to pull
off because you can't work on them as
easily
you can't Workshop them because you do
all white rooms now
um yeah so so
thank you for watching they're called
rallies but yeah
but no I love Pete's girl that peace
girl you know what joke is good when I'm
writing and I'm like how did that Pete's
girl go joke go because I want to like
see the formula yeah like some type of
Gaffigan has a lot of jokes or I'm like
that formula is so good I didn't know
you could do jokes like that you know
like David tells uh I used to do drugs
that was way over there that's such a
great joke
if you said what's the best joke ever
written
uh
uh a tells joke I'm I'm afraid to travel
maybe because when I was a kid my father
beat me with a globe yes it's like and I
didn't even say it right amazing like
[__] Flawless joke right so there are
certain guys
where when you're writing you're like oh
you already got here yeah for sure ah
[__] I feel bad for black Comics having
to write against Chappelle and rock yeah
and Patrice because it's like oh they
like they're all on the same crime scene
right and those guys keep finding the
murder weapons and like other guys are
like ah [__] that's a great Point yeah
they got the collar yeah like I had a I
had a hair follicle like no I have the
gun you know no one touches rock on
angles he always has the angle where
you're like oh how did we all miss that
one it's right they hit the angle uh
when the whole Bill Clinton Monica thing
happened and I've never seen a special
by the way I saw it live he was like uh
Hillary's running for president why
would you want to work in the place you
got cheated on yeah if my girl cheated
on me at Bennigan's I ain't applying to
Bennigan's or whatever the hell the joke
was and I'm like that was right there
nobody caught that he got it he told me
not to open with that dog joke really
yeah he's like you can't open with a dog
I'm like it's a new one though yeah
right but why did he say that because
it's a dog because he was subscribed in
the thing of uh once you've done it's
hacky
so
you can't uh I know what he means by uh
I open with it by the way but like I
know what he means by um
if you ever watched a special and
someone goes down one of these Lanes
you're like oh boy yeah yeah and I think
there's a bit of that in the audience
also where there's a little bit of a
little bit like you can't
certain topical [__] you guys are smart
that you've hire someone in the crowd to
yell out a copy
um plants are getting expensive where I
mean what are they 150 a show now it's
[__]
hey folks black tux baby
we're brought to you by black tux I wore
these at the wedding we got measured we
got some in the mail we're gonna wear it
on the show we're pumped black tux makes
it super easy to get top quality
guaranteed to fit tux without leaving
the house just take the black tux fit
quiz pick a style and boom your tux is
delivered 10 days before the day you
need it plenty of time to try it on and
make sure it wears you well thanks to
the black tux fit guarantee if it
doesn't fit perfectly order a better
size within a day of receiving the less
than great fitting one and they'll send
another one right away at no extra cost
holy [__] that's incredible scroll up
will you
um yeah here you go I love black tiger I
warm up my wedding and I warm up my
wedding after party I got a
red velvet Blazer they look good as hell
we got picks in it together yeah those
are pulled out Sally took some Beauties
uh hold on I need the copy all right
rent or buy oh wait if you prefer the
in-store experience the black tux has
showrooms of all across the country
they're expert fit Specialists will help
you find the perfect style and make sure
it fits just right renter by the tux is
the best place to go when you need a
tuxedo for a wedding or a special night
and right now when you go to
theblacktucks.com drunk and use code
drunk you'll save 20 off your order
that's t-h-e-b-l-a-c-t-u-x
jesus.com drunk code drunk to save 20
bucks
the black tux
black tuck Subway cut it quit
blacktuck.com drunk promo code drunk all
right
hey look at that red velvet baby you
look good and I bought those cup
fleur-de-lis cufflinks the day you look
cool though dude I look wrecked I was
really really hurting that night but I
had to get get through the wedding you
know the worst thing in the world is
going to the emergency vet at 3am
because you didn't know something was
wrong with your cat that's why I use
pretty litter to keep tabs on my cat's
Health the odor you should have read
this one mark the odor trapping crystals
change color to alert you to possible
health problems
I treat my cat like my child
so pretty litters Health detector helps
me to be a proactive about my cat's
well-being uh do I have a cat possibly
nah you don't know if I do it yeah Mark
does it's so much easier to use in
regular cat litter too pretty little
super light crystals minimize the mess
and dust and the crystals last up to a
month so you're not constantly having to
scoop the cat box
pretty litter helps keep my cat healthy
and keeps odors down you and your cat
Are Gonna Love pretty litter as much as
we do go to prettylitter.com drunk to
save 20 on your first order that's
pretty litter.com drunk to save 20
prettylitter.com
I use this it is good stuff cat shits on
it every day
all right all right today's episode is
sponsored by PayPal honey the easy way
to save When shopping on your iPhone or
computer when you learn about a sale on
the sly you feel like a boss honey is
the free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your cart it
supports over thirty thousand stores
online ranging from Tech and gaming
products to popular fashion brands and
even food delivery
I love honey I've saved money on shoes
sweaters uh
booze you name it anything you buy
online imagine shopping in your favorite
site when you check out the honey button
appears and all you have to do is Click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for the coupons I can
find if honey finds a working coupon
you'll watch prices drop oh yeah I love
this I use all the time oh yeah Honey's
good we love honey and you will too I
never go shopping without it honey
doesn't work on just on desktops it's on
your iPhone too activated on Safari or
your phone save on the go if you don't
already have honey you could be straight
up missing out on deals
good bye honey wait I'm getting it oh by
getting it you're getting yourself a
solid and supporting the podcast get
honey PayPal for free at joinhoney.com
wmb that's join honey.com slash wnb wmbd
oh geez wmbd we might be drunk wmbd
sorry uh I've been drinking wmd what is
this weapons of mass destruction I'll
tell you come on
cut that
um the uh the the uh keep it in
um the uh I had nothing to do with any
of this
um I'm just minding my own business uh
like Mike Myers right now you push does
not care about black people
uh the uh you you can't
uh what the [__] was I talking about uh
Rock the dog joke oh yeah that you once
you hear it you kind of roll your eyes
and like you kind of so you want he
wanted you to earn oh no you can't talk
about you boy you can't talk about like
rock and Will Smith you had like a day
yeah of course before the audience was
like what yes what are you talking about
I know even if you're
kind of like Chris can't I know it's
hacky for him and he was there right it
was his face like I'm sure he will but
I'm saying oh my God people are still
making references to it and you're like
all right you know and then that's his
life like I can't imagine every day
people just being like so what like
here's what I thought about it he's
probably like [__] off just yeah I'm
sure it's unbearable the problem is
audiences are getting so Savvy now with
Reddit and all these [__] on the the
blogs and whatever like they just know
about comedy so they'll be like oh
that's hacky and I'm like you guys
didn't know about hacky yeah they even
know about they know about tags they'll
be like oh that's a good tag I'm like
you're like a guy in a cubicle you're
just saying tag but it's also good that
they're this it's good because I'll take
out a notebook on stage sometimes and
they start applauding like they really
they like that I'm working [__] out
something they think you're throwing
your act out get this they'll listen to
podcasts about it about it I I couldn't
imagine [__] believe it where they
get drunk
but it's all the same but it is all the
same like that's why it's it's all like
the level of popularity and to your
earlier point of like there is no other
category no one talks yeah no one's
communicating ideas besides Comedians
and like politicians a little bit Yeah
and even that's censored and yeah caged
and and I'm not saying like we're the
modern day philosophers it's just a but
you see like
why people go to 10 comedy shows a year
yeah I was like yeah you'll if you
Seinfeld had a great joke about uh
everyone at the comedy show is the funny
person in their group where it's like
you guys all think you're funny right
you're like the funny one uh so they're
all the funny and then they get to go
and watch
someone who's like all right he's
funnier than me but like most of these
comedians yeah are not better than me a
couple of them but it's scary like you
know black friends are like you're like
hanging out with me like oh man this is
all better than my act and then I'll see
you guys on Twitter I'll write a joke on
Twitter I'm like kind of proud of and
somebody'll go you should have said this
and I'm like
yeah he's right and this is some guy in
Ohio you know with two kids yeah but how
much it's rare what's happening in some
of those tweets that's true let's be
honest some of these tweets are fun
um and some of these are two for deals
with the plants you go it's 150 you'll
yell out a premise and you'll do a tweet
the next day I was proud of that hey R
Kelly's not getting covid-19 too old for
him tweet
joking good for you thank you um we're
just like two friends watching and
everybody like whatever you got to do
pal
whatever you got to do to get off god
well that's where the business is now is
where I'm like oh I haven't tweeted in
two days let me throw something up just
so people don't forget who I'm alive
yeah do you how often do you well you
guys
are never not on the road right now but
like your you've never you don't go like
I really special now I'll stop it what
else do we do yeah just stay in the city
and write
we've talked about this where I don't
really write well at home I don't the
seller's a tough place to write for me
because you're literally following some
new guy who's got a killer 15 yeah right
and he's just ripping I go up there and
I'm gonna do I'm gonna open mic it I can
do new [__] but I I write better on the
road same or if I do an hour in one of
those side rooms at the cellar and you
have that hotel room that's just quiet
and empty yeah you kind of can do
nothing but work and jack off and you're
like I'm not jacking off I'm working
that's like that's like no jacking off
for those first couple weeks maybe like
a late night one now you're right tell
me more about this
okay so there I was the Best Western
this is interesting now what does just
know but I am curious what do you mean
you won't jack off no I just will try to
like work on my next three hours like
just work just [__] you ever you ever
take like 50 minutes of you jack off and
you you take 50. yes 50 minutes and
you're like why did I just [__] spend
that much time totally because you were
using your minds and not watching porn
uh but and you're like what did I just
do I think that's we're doing foreplay
with ourselves oh yeah oh but also
keeping a boner for 50 minutes I mean
our age and all right pretty good you do
have to pick at a certain point you meet
those people who still play video games
and I'm like you can't jack off and play
video games that's a good point when do
you get [__] done yeah yeah well that's
do you guys play video games no don't
touch them I I'm I have the console and
I never use it I just don't play it I I
that's a funny thing that I never
thought of that that may be
why we are in the higher percentage oh
interesting jokes written yeah because I
don't I added
15 years ago I was like I can't do this
yeah I literally can't you just feel I
Can't Live Another Life yes I can't be a
character and go like I got a new shirt
my character just I got a new pack right
with they got the the CR the uh funny
socks yeah and that like I can't I
cannot focus it's the same feeling after
you jack off where you're like what was
that for why'd I do that you know at
least have you do you not have orgasms
I do but do you not have regret
after a jerk not after okay
are you guys watching of age porn is
that why
any links uh got it
uh for his sake uh yeah I don't I don't
regret jerking I mean I the only thing I
regret is the time I'd wait yeah no I'm
with you on that but it also feels like
a silly to do it if you jack off 50
straight minutes you're not like [__] I
could have been you don't have that
writing guilt where you're like well
it's just weird but I want to enjoy look
how much time do you have Sam I wanna I
need to know more are you wearing this
hat while you're jerking off three
minutes I don't want to [__] just do
three minutes yeah that feels like weird
yeah a quickie with yourself is weird
what a quickie with yourself no exactly
right so we gotta find a uh a middle
ground that's like coming out and doing
your closer exactly yeah you gotta open
up eight minutes gotta pull the notes
Out twelve yeah but it is say when you
get two into a jerk like you got a one
leg up on the bathroom counter and
you're in the mirror and you're sweating
and the water's been running for a while
and you're like oh you [__] on the
sink you've been married too long yeah
this is a year ago the maid screaming
housekeeping [__] you that that helps me
um somebody I won't say who it was but I
at Montreal one year
this is slightly related he had sex with
the maid what at the hotel and he's like
afterward I wanted to cry it was such a
miracle I'm like yeah this like never
happened well this is Silvio Berlusconi
new faces
uh no I don't who it is is crazy wow
that's so really it's he's not like oh
yeah that guy
it's it's like not categorically that
different from mouth wow
um yeah so pretty great
oh Lavelle Crawford I didn't know you
had it on you son of a big gun
um anyhow so so you guys so how do you
write jokes I'm kidding yeah um what's
your problem so you guys never and do
you feel like the people at the
beginning of the tour get a shittier
show than people at the end of the tour
I don't know this difference because the
beginning of the tour you're all amped
up by the end of tour I'm grizzled I'm
hungover all the jokes work yeah
but I'm about to do a special and I'm
terrified of this new beginning like the
whole starting over thing like you just
started over so did you
well I was lucky that I had
I wrote the show kind of before covet uh
so then I would like put jokes in during
so when I was done I had like
40. oh wow 30 to 40. I've never been to
that that's why I was able to go on tour
Neil vernon.com uh I was able to go on
tour like immediately like while I was
having a like a hit of yeah press I was
like I'll put tickets on sale wow that's
really nice what about you because are
you going out there with new [__] I'd
say like 45 of it's pretty good and then
the rest of it is you know I'll throw an
old bit of topical bit I'll figure stuff
out do people know that it's an old bet
can you tell in the laugh like ah
there's a bit of they know this maybe
some of them do but at the same time
like you know uh
I do it at the very end so it's kind of
like yeah whatever it's like you know I
don't think they care they also at this
point with like the whiskey and the
podcast and like the sort of they just
want to spend time with you guys I know
I know they want to they just want to be
around you which is dangerous because
I've seen a lot of comics go from comic
and then podcast is their main main
thing after a while and you want to stay
I think comic first yeah
um but I don't know how to avoid it
because Burr has had a podcast his whole
but he's always that's what I'm saying
like his it never I don't know what he
does on the like there are people like
pass alone though which is like it is
kind of like Marin's opening too it's
kind of figuring out a bit you can sure
yeah sure you know yeah so I'm always
curious like
you can tell when someone podcasts a lot
because they get huge responses for
something you don't understand exactly
exactly they're doing outside jokes and
stuff yeah and they're like yeah yeah
you guys know my pet mouse yeah yeah
right
um we have to take a vow today to never
fall into that trap guy
um
and how's that marriage oh yeah it's
it's the same it's the same but now if
you [__] we [__] in the living room
last night and it was like oh wow
this is this is new again yeah how did
you end up well I don't want to get too
much you never
how often were you [__] two years ago
and how often are you [__] know well
uh I'd say two years ago I was probably
like I don't know twice a week three
times a week and then now it's probably
the road is tough and good because when
you come back you immediately bang
because I'm all like I gotta I can't
walk straight up so you're doing that
from The New York Times that Trump was
doing the impression
but uh but yeah so then then you get
that immediate bang which is good but
then you kind of have your married thing
where you're like well we banged right
we're good for a couple of nights that
was like today right yeah like that was
three days ago exactly exactly is it is
there like a time or do you make a move
would you say do you want to [__] what's
the we try to do we did I heard a good
piece of advice keep dating after you're
married other people no keep dating um
your wife so like I took her out we went
to a jazz club we got a couple drinks
and then uh I was making an athletic
Green in the kitchen while drunk and she
uh made a promo code
banging yeah yeah exactly and then uh
yeah we went at it went on the other day
I was I just went on stamps.com and uh
man it got her in the mood it was crazy
that stamp won't fall off the letter
I'll tell you that it'll be sticky have
you got that purple carrot no when I'm
with cooking a meal with a new gal is
one of my favorite things to do like all
my erection too the purple carrot
but after that you might need a blue
apron and I think it helps I heard Gary
gallman say like during the panda we're
all kind of getting a little stir crazy
you know he goes shave guys if you shave
it like keeps you sane and I think with
a lady if you're married she was like
wearing high heels and these thigh-high
things and all that cleavage so she got
all dolled up and I think that made her
more into it as well so that's the part
of just the the cleavage and the thing
is that the other night or that was that
was the other night so like she was
looking great and she felt great because
women everything were like I can't have
sex if I don't feel sick it's so isn't
it the craziest I've never felt sexy so
weird where they're like I don't feel
anything you're like [__] get in line
exactly that's not the point of this the
point of this is not to feel sexy I'd be
a virgin I think I said not to feel safe
for a second
yeah because I related to that too well
me neither you'll leave at some
hey Sam can I speak to you for a second
over here
um yeah you don't yeah that thing of
they have to I'm also it's a thing I've
noticed about women again this is so
like Broad and hacky like women's
outfits but they think outfits
are like an opening move they think it's
an activity oh interesting they think
it's like if we go like we took a
helicopter to the party right we dropped
in on a helicopter on the lawn that's
how they go like well I was wearing
those heels right right or like I was
wearing my red uh caftan or whatever
yeah yeah no you're so it's a weird
thing where it's like a big it's like
the first the opening chess move totally
and she'll be like we have this event
coming up I have no clothes all you do
is buy clothes and you have no clothes
now yeah you have two closets full of
horror you got three closets full of
nothing to wear yeah I'm gonna come out
of one but uh but yeah it's like all
these clothes and she's like I need I
need an outfit it's like having needing
a new car or something well that that's
exactly right they it's maybe it's like
new bits maybe it's like new bits where
they want they when we say we have like
we if we have to speak at an event
that's the same amount of pressure
exactly them like oh I Gotta Give a
toast they're like
I have to give my outfit is a toast
right right like they have I it's like
yeah there's something like weirdly like
what do you think has happened but
someone else made your toast
yes but she'll watch all these 90 day or
what the Bachelor and um Housewives all
these [__] shows and I'm like why do
you watch it she's like I love the
outfits she's looking at their outfits
like we look at bits like oh that's
right people tell you about your did
they like your outfit on the Netflix
mine yeah yeah you had a cool outfit
remember what people say like women
especially like I really like your shirt
yeah you're like yeah shirts look at
this thing Jesus yeah but yeah what are
you gonna wear really just no iron yeah
I don't see the big deal about shirts
gay Dracula right now
what's the big deal
I get it because Fashion's important to
me also gay Dracula there's a free
shirts of somebody's band they sent me
I'm like a Raglan or whatever you call
these but it's just wrinkled yeah it'll
iron out we're in the same shirt next
week it says fart nuggets another band
uh I do feel like the three of us have
the same maybe it's a call it autism
call it really liking comedy yeah like
whenever I hear someone go someone sent
me a clip of like these guys talk about
you guys I remember you guys going like
oh that [__] guys it's got a great
life yeah like talking about me having a
bunch of Comedy activities
doing different combinations that's
hilarious and but it's I I agree with
you do you know what I mean like I agree
with you about like yeah this is fun
it's the best and it's like uh exciting
I'm excited that I'm in comedy that's
why I don't need to play video games you
don't need a second life because you
like your life yes right it's not gonna
be better than going to the club and
getting a huge [__] laugh yeah yeah
you're getting a new bit to work and
that's that's what I'm talking about the
regret and the shame from the the master
being I know I need to do it to clear
[__] out but I still feel shame because
I'm like nothing makes me feel as good
as a new joke will make me feel that
right you know but can you
squeeze the joke out like that pardon me
don't fart
wait a minute I know you look I know you
wanna I know your [__] is doing a
Roger Rabbit right now
that's the compromise
do you see it can work
um no it's hard to write new jokes but I
think the challenge then is like well
can I at least get like a good topical
one something that's like I get extra
points because I clearly wrote it that
day yeah like a headline thing yeah it's
like even if it's not great it's just
keeping your [__] tight the the machine
is gonna stay strong if I keep working
at it right it's also boring if you
don't have a new joke like there are
nights where if I go to the store I live
in L.A uh we have a seller in L.A called
the store and uh and uh if I had don't
have a new joke I'm like what am I doing
this for
like what am I to I know it works so
what am I doing I'm calibrating at it
like again again there's something to be
said for like just getting on stage and
doing it but if you don't have at least
a new line or something it's like what
the [__] am I I know but you feel bad
about yourself and that you say like you
know marketing a lot of people yell [__]
out and stuff but we it is boredom
because we are on the road every week
and it's like how many times can I do
these jokes I need to challenge myself I
need I need to come up with something
new it it's boredom from that new 45
that I'm just like what else is I need
something else I see guys I love my
accent
every single word how'd those 80s guys
do like Lena was like I'm not doing a
special I'm not giving it away yeah and
I'm like aren't you sick of it don't you
want to do a new thing about whatever
but he's he's got a weird thing on here
he oh I think he would do it I think he
would too he's playing Burning Man
all right
um the uh the uh he's got a new injury
is the problem I know you're right that
guy's staying topical with injuries
he'll tickle your ribs uh all right
they're broken
um the uh he's a I was gonna say you've
heard of Blue Collar Comedy welcome to
broken collar yeah
guys come on I gotta stay tight guys I
he can take it on the chin all right
um the uh
he watches every special oh he's a
psycho he loves Michelle hilarious it's
really funny that he it's just odd like
where he knows he knows him yeah he
knows you too he knows him he knows you
hmm wow that's wild why would why would
he know him and not you yeah I don't
know I'm just low self-esteem yeah but
yeah I mean he watched my Comedy Central
spot like really he watches the Amazon
specials wow that's how deep into comedy
this guy is he's not touching peacock
though no peacock's a line too far uh
nobody's that injured
[Music]
Jay we're all out of specials on Netflix
how about Paramount plus
Peak I put that new Cosby on
um I went to Cosby one of his I went to
his Comedy Central special that I think
they shelved oh I remember that damn
that guy had
excellent jokes well he's a great guy I
mean he's a [__] amazing comic yeah
um but you know yeah if a NFL player
hits their wife the touchdown still
counts yeah
um clip it Harvey Weinstein great movies
yeah great movie Yes Yes Woody Allen
yeah there you go Picasso
um now you're going too far yeah yeah
I'm drinking here please cut that
actually please cut it because it's just
I don't I literally just going through
people yeah yeah um so uh so yeah Leno
knows every
comedian wow Morgan I'm gonna be like
that I'm gonna be an old man in a
rocking chair watching you know some
twink do 20 minutes in a wheelchair well
yeah do you got you guys don't wanna uh
that's so many questions about this new
special tour of Comedy well I'm just
saying you gotta have a hook you know
he's gonna be like it sounds like he's
got a couple
um uh the Pokemon you gotta see roller
twinks this guy one of the best have you
seen roller drink roller drinks gonna be
there tonight I'll be right down hello
StubHub
Mark Normand is here to see you that's
it kid you ever got that good oh hold on
a second
you know you got jokes you got no legs
that joke's got legs though
um the uh you wanna like I don't want to
die doing comedy but like just do it as
long as yeah yeah oh you go Don Rickles
you know all the way so do you feel like
Joan River well I guess there's like
right but Rickles Joan was doing good
rooms Rickles was doing good rooms would
you wanna
like at a certain point if you felt like
you were stuck
at a certain like level that was too
hard yeah that would be tough like would
you keep yeah you want to be Rickles you
don't want to be more tall basically at
the end yeah oh what was he doing I
think he was just doing tough moves I
don't think he was selling tickets he
wasn't really even doing tough for him
he was doing a place
in like in Marin County like a theater
once a week but people swear he was
Lenny Bruce like he was that level he
was contextually yeah no one had done
that before and a better writer I'd say
than Lenny I agree there's a documentary
about Mortal that's like oh really yeah
but what is it how did he just lose it
how did he lose all the momentum I never
huge wasn't I met him there was
documentary
called I think uh you gotta be something
or the loyal opposition
um uh uh Mort Saul It's s a h all that's
what I got
um just put down that's what I got boss
um loyal opposition oh interesting uh
yeah it's an American Master's loyal
position but I remember having it and uh
me and Chappelle watched it and then
whoa we were like we should put him in a
sketch yeah and he passed what he didn't
like the sketch or whatever I think he
didn't like sketch but apparently he
he's one of those guys who doesn't think
anyone's funny right he just got so like
[__] everyone I'm I think he was just a
big narcissist it's my understanding of
it wow Woody Allen's hero yeah
um there's a funny Woody Allen story
where if you can watch it Bob Whitey
directed it who did a ton of stuff yeah
um but any just uh Bob Whitey did a a uh
uh Vonnegut documentary oh wow
um but uh there's funny Woody Allen
Mort's haul story I ended up meeting him
went to she was like just kind of like
cordial but not especially like warm
respectful or like just kind of like
what do I I'll do like they tell me or
something I'm not gonna and uh Woody
Allen's story is
uh mortal went to Woody Allen uh
Premiere this is how long ago this month
uh they used to open Woody Allen's
movies and uh there was a Premiere party
and uh Mort Saul went to the premiere
party and uh the security guard wouldn't
let him in and he's like tell Woody the
guy who changed his life is here wow and
uh Woody Allen came out and goes Mort
change it back
[Music]
um but uh be a more yeah you don't wanna
you either want to just quit Johnny
Carson you either want to be Johnny
Carson right where you like dis I'm not
participating
but the idea of like I think you'd be so
bored
well it's I guess it's border humiliated
or Ford or like perpetually bruised ego
yeah why but you want to end on a high
note too you don't want to be that
you're the loud guy yeah but look I I
don't think Rickles or Joan were they
were doing good though yeah I'm saying
them to Mortals like would you rather be
do you get out like on a like just on a
decline right or do you just stop doing
it and like Rodney would do dates kind
of I think oh really like but they were
not regular and then he'd only know and
do five minutes and it was like
yeah but yeah it seems like how to end
it I saw Carlin and oh one and it was
rough that I we could tell by the way
you said oh
it was at a casino though in Biloxi
Mississippi oh my God so it wasn't his
fault but he got heckled for an hour and
he was just snapping on people and he
was trying to do like the I'm uptown but
I'm downloaded I'm back door but I've
been front mode or whatever and they
were just like ah do the dirty words you
know and he was like shut up you [__]
[__] I'll put my dick right in your ass
and all that and it was like whoa but
again it was at a casino but I was a
huge Carlin fan and seeing that was like
it was like a wake-up call like oh
comedy is rough yeah
yeah this is one of the best of all time
and it was like he was cursing people
out no one was listening people were
throwing beer cans and [__] I saw prior
and speaking I'm like that's crazy and
then I'm like I saw Pryor in a
wheelchair what Dave opened for him in
like 93. he was he was a wheelchair
twink that's exactly right
um and um but black you know what I mean
yeah it's a different it's kind of
different than wheelchair checking hello
StubHub
um
and Dave open for him and it was like uh
he
Pryor kind of couldn't he didn't have it
like he didn't like he couldn't really
remember his jokes and he uh it was just
kind of a bummer yeah and people it
became like a Revival meeting where
people kind of yelling out like we love
you rich and all that stuff right but it
was like a hard damn it was just like
man life is wild I know it's so long
they say that about Bob Dylan my friend
saw Bob Dylan he's like it was it was
rough like he can't understand him but
you couldn't I saw about Dylan 20 years
ago you don't even know what song it is
till the third verse wow they're like oh
is this [__] blowing in the wind
well they as long as you still get
booked you can still work but like in
sports you're not you don't see like
Bill Russell wasn't playing five years
ago yeah you know and that's kind of
what it it's like and it feels better
because you have to get out
but do you go to the places where people
want to see you I know like do you go to
block or do you go to like down markets
yeah and pretend
that it's still you almost need the
Vegas because the Vegas will prop you up
they'll help you sell tickets though
they'll be Glitz and glamor there's a
little dignity to it almost Carrot Top
having said that that's he has a pretty
good life yeah yeah also care that's
[__] funny he's funny yeah he became
the punch line for everyone it just
became like an easy one for people the
props obviously in there
um I tell you how it became a punchline
but I'm gonna need a prop
um uh you yeah it's it became a
punchline for people outside of comedy
to know like that that's a hacky
reference or something it's like the
show we're at the Chuckle Hut you're
like shut up exactly and somebody made a
great point on Twitter they said should
it be carrot bottom
because he's the top of a carrot is
green
go on then what'd they say I'm just
saying it's a good point
this Twitter sounds pretty great
all right that was one of those guys
when you're like what are you doing dude
well I don't know communion should not
be on how do you
I said this to Taylor on she did my
podcast you came up I like jokingly
whatever
um but uh but
I don't know like I I change sort of
Life philosophies pretty regularly do
you know what I mean so like he just was
like oh let me try steroids yeah let me
see if that it's like changing
steroids is another
yeah right there there he's going with
like a he's wearing makeup how did my ex
play into that
he's wanting to bring her up she's on
Roy no no because I we I I put it on
Instagram yesterday about like
just questioning your own behavior like
how should I approach
really like I'm sure you deal with this
where what I was saying earlier about
relationships
and you're like
ah Like Me and Bobby were talking about
like is David Spade
a dream
or like should I not do what Spade has
done in terms of relationships just
never get married be single
I don't know interesting and like I
don't [__] know I changed my mind all
the time I don't think there's like a
prototype I mean it's what's right for
you and I think if you're growing you
don't know what the dream is in five
years you might have a different that's
what I'm saying like Carrot Top was like
steroids [__] it I mean look at
Chappelle Chappelle's like the skinny
guy go back to that pictures babe
uh yeah okay doing great so uh yeah like
yeah like Dave at a certain point like
so no I a Fate's [__] hilarious I'm
saying like as a lifestyle how
I don't know how to be any I don't know
what to be I don't know so like with
character yeah I'm not gonna [__] go
to Vegas do you go on dates
yeah so you're trying I mean you're
trying to meet people yeah but there are
times when I'll be on an app going like
why am I it's like
looking at like uh collectible sneakers
where I'm like I don't need these
[__]
I don't need like new turkey low dunks
yeah I don't need the Yeezy 750s it's a
fun idea yeah
it's like past the time like what are
they charging yeah
um yeah there's a look but like you know
I but then I go like am I tricking that
I don't think I'm triggering them but
but you know like how to live is it like
a heart like you got it all figured out
yeah well I'd say I mean how many Bill
Burr had a great bit about marriage
being dumb then cut the big marriage and
he's got like an hour and a half of
overpopulation and has two kids exactly
and was like encouraging me to have kids
which is like I was like what do you
what I know I mean people you know they
change [__] I agree and it's what's good
right now for Neil might not be good for
him in five years so yeah you know yeah
that's why I uh that's why it's
important not to endorse anything on
your T-shirt
that's true yeah yeah gay Dracula that
may that may not be the coolest thing on
earth five years from now
they can touch a kid who knows
um well you see those people who have
like a Cosby tattoo and you're like
that's gotta be that's a rough Choice
yeah
um I had a girl
tell me that I it's it I told the story
in Rogan one time but like I had a gr I
my girlfriend this in the mid-2000s was
mentioned something like ah Dr Cosby and
I was like
what what's that tone about oh boy and
she's like beautiful mixed girl and I
was like was it and she's like uh well
no I met him on the street one time and
uh and I was like he was fattening you
up for the slaughter oh of course and
she was like no no no no and they don't
believe it and then when the story broke
I text her like what do you think of
your boy now and she wrote back like I
think his wife knew about it and he I
was supposed to meet him in Philadelphia
one time and I got the flu thankfully
yeah and uh yeah so people changed I
don't mind when a comic changes but it
bugs me into Comic changes to go with
the flow you know I like when I cut like
a Chappelle just was like I'm gonna be
buff now or Carrot Top but when I like
David Letterman who I love I feel like
he was a little snarky and fun and now
he's kind of like
I don't want to get in trouble and I'm
going to play ball I think he's just
he's older and he's kind of mellowed out
well you watch those old videos of him
being like yeah [__] an intern what
can you do and then uh and then now he's
got like uh no I think
that speech was amazing yeah then he got
it killed but I don't know what can you
do I think he looked pretty troubled by
that speech if we watched it that was
like that was like cinematic I mean it
was killing that was like pretty crazy
it was crazy and he owned up to it and
he got ahead of it and it was awesome
but I feel like I still like him I'm not
[__] on him I'm just saying now I
think he like he watched some of his
guests and he's like I respect you I
love you well I think guys like him I
think he's holding he did a podcast
recently
did a podcast recently but we'll see uh
he did uh no and he was I listened to
that one yeah and and he was apologizing
the whole time for so he's a Kevin if
you're a
if you're
imagine if you're that age right and all
the rules are changing that's what I'm
saying yeah you must it's like you got
to adapt you kind of have to adapt and
by the way you have like a staff that
are kind of relying like he likes being
like I don't know if you took away from
the interview but like he likes being in
Show Business yes he likes winning he
likes like working yeah he had one of my
favorite quotes where he said uh I could
not be famous because I'm so sensitive I
couldn't handle not being treated nicely
and I think about that all the time he's
he said yeah he said stuff like that in
the interview like he really likes his
lifestyle he likes the way so so if he
has to be a little more
like apologetic right because that
what's the alternative
[Music]
yeah on Fox news on not even the main
Fox her new special streaming on Fox oh
I didn't know that Fox streaming or
something oh wow I didn't know that yeah
more Ingram's doing the warm-up for us I
mean it's gonna be wild Argentina green
is the closer so uh wow she's gonna come
out with a with a t-shirt gun or is it a
real gun
um
so like I that's one of those things
like I don't [__] know how to be I
wouldn't know what I would do in that
situation yeah yeah it's tough to
navigate when you have bite to your act
and you're getting older I think that's
that's really what it is yeah bite is
hard to hold up
well you just seem cranky you just seem
like an old man right and if you're
vital like us yeah um uh you it feels
like he's in the same cat he's living
the same world as I am and like cool
Stick it to the whoever right right
whereas if you just are like I don't get
these but if you're the same age as
these whatever your group is yeah uh
gypsies right I think we're all thinking
gypsies
um you
yeah like it's I don't I don't know what
I would do if I were him it's it's a
tough uh landscape it's a lot of a lot
of land mines like Colin Quinn is that
great joke and his I don't know should I
say a new Joker was special I feel like
he has a he he talked about not saying
or somebody talked about not saying
someone's jokes on podcasts all right we
said about 40th this episode we've said
other comedians former jokes yeah yeah
his isn't out yet you know uh [__] I was
gonna make a point about Letterman yeah
but I do think he's like a genuinely
curious person yes and that is part of
it where it's like even when he was
snarky there was a curiosity you know uh
but then when I get in trouble
I'm curious I'm canceled what happened
to curiosity huh but you know look at a
guy like Bill Murray is like a guy who's
been polarizing right now yeah good
point I love Bill Murray you know this
is a big part of my childhood he got in
trouble on that [__] times are times
change right and that's exactly to the
like hey man go out guns Blaze and stick
to it and it's like no no no I'm not
saying he should go out guns blazing but
I just I don't I don't want him to
change for someone else I want you to
change for you maybe
well yeah but I don't think
that's how Society works I guess you're
right I guess you're right I mean if
it's it's the thing Bill Murray got away
with it for a long time because he was
like so funny right and I think his
movies are too dramatic I agree
part of the problem like Dave Chappelle
can say wild [__] and it's like ah yeah
it's funny it's fun whereas bill it's
like too many [__] too many broken
flowers yeah too many Wes Anderson
movies too many too many movies where he
wears hats like this
yeah it'll you can't be funny you can't
bite a woman's or whatever he did yeah
pulling a ponytail I think is that what
he did that's what I heard that's funny
black woman they had the hair thing it's
a difference there
not getting involved
I read an art form stiff by impenetrable
firewall nothing to do with it Sam put
yours up as well learn from me Sam hold
on a second attention
and uh what are your what are your life
goals what's your life goal I don't know
man because I mean I I like my life
right now so I'd like it to just keep
going this way and I'll I'll figure out
this seems like a better version of your
life 10 years ago
the same
basic func like same basic day-to-day
but with better money and we're working
more Fame we're working a lot like which
is great and you've started saying we
which Speaking of yourself which is
pretty healthy no I mean think about how
often we're on the road and stuff yeah
we're going hard I love it I I've always
liked this style but yeah I think at
some point I'd like to meet a woman but
like you know right now it's it's it's
tough I'm home two days a week and I'm
I'm nervous to waste one of those two
nights home
on a maybe bad date you should put this
in put this in your dating profile look
I got two nights make them count uh are
you do you have eyes on me but you don't
catch now or you weren't a catch 10
years ago obviously no a fan but like in
a woman's mind you know you got some
Fame some money some notoriety some some
credits
right yeah look who's talking amazing
baby gay Dracula himself I could be
wearing flippers right now
um do you
uh
uh do you find that comedians
get a bad rap dating wise meaning like
when I think it's like uh comedian when
I heard your comedian I was like maybe
now for sure it's probably not easy yeah
I mean just the fact that we're never
around they're like we must be a cheater
I don't think that's it I think it's
more neurotic and messy messes dark yeah
I think they think we're dark yeah we
are cynical depressed yeah stuff uh but
if that's your thing
yeah yeah gloomy unpleasant yeah if
that's your if you're into it yeah it's
also but also like [__] funny yeah
that's like [__] funny I'll tell my
lady you want to go to the SNL after
part she's like we can do that I'm like
yeah I'm a comedian and so that's pretty
cool yeah so there is that there is some
perks we can go you can go to the
Chappelle Radio City hey maybe it'll
throw me on who knows you know that's
fun yeah
um so there there's plenty of benefits
and like when you have
uh
uh you have yeah you just it's like go
to the trip you got miles yeah wow
although you're on a bus now you've
really [__] yourself on Miles yeah the
ladies don't love a bus yeah I won't do
the bus every time but the bus is
[__] fun no I know it is do you sleep
well on the bus I kind of did I've only
been on chebelle's bus a long time ago
it was the best sleep ever oh it's great
you're in that little bunk the low
Rumble cocoon I love it dude if you just
don't think about like Metallica guy
dying I just don't think about it yeah
ah you had to let them know you ruined
the bus and just just to go all the way
they uh Richard Wicked Witch of the West
like legs under the bus I believe that's
how that's how they found him I believe
oh my God yeah yeah so have you seen the
Metallica documentary oh some kind of
monster it's [__] have you seen it
yeah it's been a while it came out like
18 years it's [__] amazing really
yeah it's um it's excellent give me some
all-time doc Rex oh that one
um seven five is great
yeah that was wild that was a great one
fog of War yeah
no returned yeah there's a a guy named
Adam Curtis who makes BBC documentaries
that are insane oh really and YouTube
right yeah they're all on YouTube uh and
he made one called
he made one called hyper normalization
he made one call it's like really
they're like fill us up you'll like them
really because they're like
he made one about how Al Qaeda and the
religious right are basically the same
thing oh that's like a [__] and they
were on like an inevitable Collision
Course whoa and uh show uh the power of
nightmares
power of nightmare yeah I mean just like
the titles are [__] insane
um
there's one here yeah holy [__] what a
great premise
is that John Edwards yeah
holy [__] it's been a while
um
is Rick Crum
no one will get that that was for you
too
politicians now promised to protect us
ah it's like
they're
they're these weird there's one called
Century of the self
where he says uh
where he basically explains how
marketing started public relations PR
and marketing like Freud's nephew came
to the states and was like you wanted to
and like started working with
advertising wow started got women women
didn't smoke and then Freud's nephew
there was a like women's suffrage at
March and Freud's nephew had them all
light a cigarette up at the same time
and he called them Freedom torches wow
[__] like that like a million of those
things that's amazing um I'll watch that
one first like that's probably the
easiest it's four parts but like okay oh
we do a lot of wrecks on this point yeah
um there's the war the house I live in
you guys see that one no because I live
in like a [__] Masterpiece you ever
seen super Mensch yeah that reminds me
of that that's about that guy uh Chef
Gordon yeah he's not Mike Myers made
this yeah Mike is friends with like is
like practically yeah he produced it
yeah but he made a bus break down in the
middle of Piccadilly square or whatever
the Hell in London and it had an Alice
Cooper ad on it but it broke down so
they were trying to get it everybody saw
the ad and it's he sold out so he had
all these cool ways of like helping his
clients get bigger uh and he's like this
about the War on Drugs basically oh wow
this one calls it like a Public Enemy
Number One is drug abuse what do you do
when someone offers you drugs
[Music]
why we fight's good
time wow
[Music]
somebody down the road said drugs
okay there's no argument there but think
about where we are 30 years later
it's great the guy he did um you can see
like dates aren't going well by the way
like you want to put on uh a girl said
to me one time good luck finding someone
to watch your old man documentary
this and by the way this was 15 years
back
I don't know what's funny is the culture
has met me like now everyone wants
documentaries yeah I saw I used to see
[__] in the theaters like I saw Brothers
Keeper in the theater like [__] I
tell I think I saw half of them with a
towel like she is yeah
um I know I'm I would bet myself the
only ones in the theater I swear to God
yeah we went to the the one on uh on
Houston and Angelica no the one Sunshine
now left you guys are going the wrong
direction in film porn yeah that's a
great one yeah
um it's got a giant pillar in the middle
of what a theater yeah yeah
um
do you guys want to make TV shows or
anything Ah that's a good question good
point I think you do I think at some
point yeah I didn't even notice that he
completely flipped this and made this
blocks podcast because I don't well I am
saving the good [__] for the for them
when you guys come on
um but I because I don't want I don't
know they I don't want uh mark fart on
me and I just got to keep him busy this
is defense turned into offense yeah I do
um a TV show I don't know I mean if it
could be a like a Tosh.0 or something
like that I would do well you could
still be you but I can't act I don't
want to ride an arc and have a bunch of
bunch of dumb characters and a wacky
neighbor you don't want a doorbell
no yeah
no doorbell yeah maybe a ring camera
that could be a fun show sure that's a
good device but I still love that I
still love the old type of like like
great shows yeah part of me does want to
do that I gotta have a new spin though
like Atlanta or something you know I
don't I mean it's so hard that's the
thing is I don't whenever I think about
it
I'm like I don't want to do that to
myself you disappear for like four years
but also like your it's like being on
the road
but like way worse yeah it's just like
so much harder yeah than you can even
imagine trailers and script supervisors
video Village but it's also just casting
and locations yeah uh
what you just have so many decisions to
make I know and you gotta write it so
like and you gotta like make it improve
it make it better yep then you gotta go
press tour for it yeah it's it's just
never ending and you only get a billion
dollars
if it's good enough if it is if it's
Seinfeld you get a billion dollars right
right right
um apparently The Last of Us was the
most expensive shoot of all time or some
[__] like that so it's like it ain't
cheap I mean that's a giant production
but it's a lot and look at what it did
to mullaney I think it [__] him up
doing a TV show yeah that's fun I
haven't heard that theory I think it
[__] I mean it's special was called
Comeback Kid he's like I'm coming back
like that was tough I was I don't I mean
it was like three episodes and uh
who was Marty Jordan yeah oh yeah
classic yeah yeah great kid at one point
he wanted Paul Mooney to be in it wow I
swear to God he's like you think Mooney
would do it I love that he uses
earthquake on the road to me that's yeah
fun fantastic
um yeah so that's great that that's why
he did drugs
um that's what made him do drugs it's a
sitcom
um so all right so no so maybe a t maybe
like a but by the way like a Tosh.0 now
you could do every day
like even
like the idea it all ha it should be
like whatever however much all of us
caught
um yeah yeah exactly like if you're
gonna do a show make it like blow it out
right but yeah just to write a script
all that just seems like too much work
yeah all right great you wouldn't would
you do it no I mean I've done it yeah I
did it was a Heyday though yeah but just
the difficulty was like I don't I also
don't like
dealing with the the uh like the not the
network but just it's just like the kind
of people I don't I the thing I like
about the road is you can deal with like
a very small amount of people yes
exactly and it's like a fair thing like
I show up sell tickets I'm gonna talk
then I leave yeah I mean instead of like
okay can we grab dinner here yes yes
exactly somebody steps to everything
yeah like uh I don't want to name drop
but I've been chatting with Seinfeld and
I think the only reason he's syncing as
low as to calling me is because he's in
LA and he's shooting this movie and he's
dying yeah he's watched this he watched
the episode of Colin Quinn that's how
bored he is that's so funny I know I'm
not gonna happen though it was a good
app and Quinn's the man but I'm just
saying like he's like I gotta he's like
shaking he's like I gotta get back out
there yeah he likes comedy yeah he loves
comedy yeah so uh that's what that's
what these shows do to you they take you
away a little bit well it's he actually
I was gonna say this earlier uh he said
one time it took him four four years to
learn how to be a person
when after the show ended whoa like he
just to like talk to his wife's friends
right like PTA meetings because he was
in show mode he was just like I'm in
charge of everything I like every
decision I think he's like it's just to
be like with people right to go from
it's what we were saying earlier it's
like it's easier to be at Comic at this
point yeah than it is to be a person
completely agree and it's easy to slip
into that you know when you're at
Thanksgiving you're like this sucks oh I
gotta I gotta just fake it what am I
doing I gotta do this I don't want to be
here but you got to do it yeah but you
want to go back on the road yeah but
it's so sad that we refer to being in a
person is Faking it of course that's so
sad that's how it is yeah
it's tough
um how do you guys end this thing
I believe we plug your special blocks on
Netflix fantastic what about my road
dates great special yeah and Neil Where
Are You Gonna Be man hold on
neilbrennan.com pull that up bam oh
Madison is there a better Club in
America Madison I think sold out Salt
Lake sold out Nashville saw this coming
it's still not sold out yeah you're
doing some real rooms well I'm doing
real rooms then I'm doing fake rooms San
Diego I think is it's they're all
they're all pretty close to sold out if
not if not all the way there yeah we're
in Baltimore you're playing New Orleans
oh the joy uh uh the where am I doing in
Baltimore I don't know the lyric that's
uh that's the only place I know is that
what are you which one of you guys do
well we were magoobies guys but the
lyric is like the step up right like the
Thousand seater I don't think it's a
thousand
um but yeah so go on neilbrenner.com if
you got a good airport yeah I'm coming
yeah so I could Atlanta no Atlanta's got
well it's if you have a big airport uh
and then of course the blocks podcast
you forget oh yeah let's be on you got
that right uh we've had Letterman we had
uh love Letterman
we had uh we had who else we had we had
uh Sebastian Sebastian we had Nick at
Glazer we had Ronnie Chang this week
good list got uh you gotta get a black
[__] wagon doing black what are you
doing come on Roy's coming on
Charlemagne's coming on now we're
talking um
you got Roy we've been trying to get Roy
for months that son of a [__] it's fun
I'm sure he why he was asked him and he
lives by he'll do it all right all right
I was too scared to ask him really I
don't want a body man Bobby Lee Bobby
Lee is the champ right now
killer perfect podcast guest has no
boundaries yes yes literally has nobody
used to close by stripping right yeah
used to
we we did Uh something's burning
together and his Bert's like flipping a
burger so what's going on guys he goes
would you I was blown by a boy when I
was 12. we're like we just started and
you just opened with that that was his
opening so that was fun so that was
great that's so you could stream that as
well it's on YouTube on YouTube it's
called something's burning but great
numbers Bert yeah Bert did my podcast
too yeah oh nice yeah
um anyhow
uh this was uh we might be drunk yeah oh
yeah uh Huntington AC uh I don't know
when this comes out uh Voya Luke uh
Minneapolis use uh [__] Madison
Milwaukee yeah Boston added another one
so guys I should put up sold outs on
mine yeah because it looks cooler I just
I have a thing where I'm like afraid of
my web guy
Charleston Atlanta DC samerel.com
uh you got off these I appreciate you
doing it doing my plugs too thanks he's
the guest I'm trying to sell tickets
he's like hold on let me get that that
is no joke either [__] poor Chester a
bunch of stuff all right I'm all over
the place
picture on your website look like God
I'm a Lyle
thank you at all I know I'm scared of my
web guy
uh yeah come on now markdomencomedy.com
you know where to find me come to
Chicago God damn it and uh special and
Bodega catwhiskey.com yes we love you
drink our whiskey it's great and more
merch is coming it's so the merch is
killer oh the shirts are great in their
sweaters yeah looking good thank you
gang
I'll see you all in Hell thank you
Stephanie Stephanie I thought you had to
leave no no okay all right sorry
thank you go see Stephanie in her bar
the vegetarian Depot no abcb abcv
all right comedy
Sunday
[Music]
dangerous
out to lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]